A FAVORABLE LIGHT IN THESE
HEARINGS, STAY TUNED.
>> Sean: I WILL PUT YOU IN THE
KNOW COLUMN.
GAS PRICES, THIS IS AWFUL.
HORRIFIC LEVELS.
OVER $6 A GALLON ON AVERAGE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
JUST AS DONALD TRUMP PREDICTED.
WOW.
KEEP IN MIND, THAT DOESN'T JUST
MEAN HIGHER PRICES AT THE PUMP.
THAT MEANS HIGHER PRICES TAKE
HEAT AND COOL YOUR HOME AND FOR
EVERY PRODUCT YOU BUY AT EVERY
STORE YOU GO TO.
AS "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" PUT
IT, THIS TRICKLES DOWN TO
EVERYTHING, EVEN YOUR POTATO
SALAD.
DON'T FORGET, WHATEVER YOU BUY
SHIPPED IN A TRUCK, THEY USE
DIESEL AND MUCH OF IT IS MADE IN
A FACTORY OR FARM THAT NOW FACES
RISING ENERGY COSTS.
BY THE WAY, LOOK AT THE PRICE OF
FERTILIZER.
IT'S THROUGH THE ROOF.
BY THE WAY, THAT PRICE ALSO WAS
WRAPPED IN PLASTIC.
THAT TOO IS MADE WITH OIL.
ACCORDING TO JENNIFER GRANHOLM,
WE JUST NEED TO SUCK IT UP
BECAUSE THE CLIMATE CAN'T WAIT,
SHE SAID.
SHE'S BASICALLY SHOVING HER
MIDDLE FINGER IN THE FACE OF ALL
OF YOU, EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN
SAYING F YOU, CLIMATE CHANGE IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN YOUR
FINANCIAL LIFE STRUGGLES.
BECAUSE OF THESE FAILED
POLICIES, ECONOMIC AND ENERGY,
64% OF AMERICANS RIGHT NOW ARE
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK AND
WE GET A LECTURE BY THIS OUT OF
TOUCH THAT DOESN'T KNOW JACK
ABOUT REAL LIFE.
ACCORDING TO HER, GREEN ENERGY
TRANSFORMATION TO LEAD TO PEACE
IN OUR TIME.
THE ENTIRE ADMINISTRATION IS
LOCKED INTO THIS CLIMATES
ALARMIST RELIGIOUS CULT, WATCH.
>> THE CLIMATE IS NOT GOING TO
WAIT ON OUR EFFORT TO CONFRONT
AUTOCRATS.
BOTH CRISES NEED ADDRESSING NOW.
AS MINISTER RYAN HAS SAID, IS
CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION COULD BE
THE PEACE PROJECT OF OUR TIME.
BUT PEACE ALWAYS COMES AFTER
STRUGGLE.
SO LET'S GIVE THIS PIECE PROJECT
THE FOCUS AND THE COMMITMENT AND
THE RESOURCES OF A WARTIME
EFFORT.
OUR MARSHALL PLAN.
>> Sean: WITH REACTION, FORMER
TRUMP SECRETARY OF ENERGY
RICK PERRY.
I IMAGINE IF YOU WERE STILL
ENERGY SECRETARY YOU WOULDN'T BE
DOING A DEAL WITH IRAN, BEGGING
OPEC TO PRODUCE MORE OIL, AND
WOULDN'T BE CONSIDERING
IMPORTING OIL FROM IRAN OR
VENEZUELA.
BUT I'M JUST GUESSING.
>> A YEAR AND A HALF AGO, WE
WOULDN'T NEED TO DO ANY OF THOSE
THINGS.
AMERICA WAS LEADING THE WORLD IN
THE PRODUCTION OF ENERGY.
WE WERE DOING WHAT DONALD TRUMP
HAD ASKED US TO DO, AND WE WERE
MAKING EUROPE SAFER.
WE HAD THE IRANIANS ON THEIR
KNEES.
THE CHINESE WERE PAYING
ATTENTION TO US, VERY
RESPECTFULLY I MIGHT ADD.
AND RUSSIA WASN'T ABOUT TO TAKE
ON THE UNITED STATES.
ALL THAT CHANGED IN A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME, SEAN.
AND WHAT THE SECRETARY OF ENERGY
IS TALKING ABOUT HERE, IT'S A
PIECE OF SOMETHING ALL RIGHT.
IT'S A PIECE OF JUNK.
THE IDEA THAT YOU ARE GOING TO
BRING AMERICA TO ITS KNEES IN
THIS EFFORT TO CHASE AFTER THIS
ISSUE OF THE CLIMATE WHEN THEY
WON'T FACE THE FACTS, AMERICAN
CLEAN ENERGY WAS REDUCING THE
EMISSIONS IN THE WORLD, AND WE
COULD TO CONTINUE TO BE DOING
THAT.
WE COULD BE REPLACING INDIAN
COAL WITH AMERICAN NATURAL GAS.
WE COULD HAVE BEEN REPLACING
COLD PLANTS IN EUROPE WITH
AMERICAN NATIONAL GAS.
THAT WOULD MAKE A REAL REDUCE OF
OMISSIONS, NOT TO MENTION WHAT
COULD BE HAPPENING OUT THERE IF
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD EMBRACE
SMALL MODULAR ACTORS.
>> JOE IS WILLING TO ALLOW 40
YEAR INFLATION HIGH COSTING THE
AVERAGE FAMILY ANYWHERE BETWEEN
3500 OR FIVE GRAND A YEAR, THE
HIGHEST GAS PRICES WE'VE EVER
HAD.
COMPROMISE OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
AND BEGGED THE WORLD'S WORST
COUNTRIES TO DO DEALS WITH US.
THAT'S HIS POLICY?
>> SEAN, IT'S AMAZING TO ME THAT
WE GOT THE ANSWER RIGHT HERE IN
FRONT OF US.
THESE PEOPLE...
IT'S LIKE TWO KIDS, AND ONE OF
THEM JUST CAN'T SAY "I WAS
WRONG" WHEN THE FACT OF THE
MATTER EVERYBODY KNOWS THEY WERE
WRONG WITH THEIR ENERGY POLICY.
THEY KNOW THAT AMERICA HAS THE
ABILITY TO NOT ONLY STABILIZE
THE WORLD OUT THERE, BUT BECAUSE
OF OUR ABUNDANCE OF ENERGY WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO INTO
EUROPE, WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE TO RUSSIA.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO PUT UP WITH
YOUR NONSENSE.
HE WAS PAYING ATTENTION.
WE KNEW HE HAD HIM LITERALLY
OVER A BARREL, SO TO SPEAK.
AND THIS PRESIDENT LET HIM UP,
MAKING DEALS WITH THE IRANIANS.
HE GOES AND BAGS THESE COUNTRIES
THAT DON'T LIKE US TO GIVE US
THEIR FUEL.